it's time for screen junkies movie
fights Oh what in the world you guys
movie fights it's happening it's not
live though movie fights pre-recorded
hashtag but we can still use the hashtag
movie fights live we can also use the
hashtag owl Nation hoot hoot Percival's
in the house like a hostage video we've
got a very special show we're continuing
the run up the Dan marilla thon people
so Dan's greatest competitors and summed
are just like favorite movie fight
players coming back to square off
against the ultimate champion Dan Merle
as a little reminder movie fights moves
from a weekly show to a monthly show
behind a paywall it's gonna be
pay-per-view I'm just kidding oh you
know I'm just kidding wrong movie fights
still free as always but moving to
monthly and we've got an awesome I'm
very excited about this so let's just
meet everybody first up you know this
guy from podcast the ride and all over
screen junkies and all over thank you no
I you're miss you're misremembering I
didn't actually have one eye but I
remember yours oh you didn't have a
screen junkies Plus show that was a
cooking show the weirdest movie foods no
I was not I was not on high enough on
the food chain they don't think I didn't
have one either so it takes one to know
one
ah Carlson thanks for being here brother
having me uh this gentleman oh my gosh
he is back the man the myth the legend
mr. Nick Mundy hi and the reigning movie
fights champion thank you for coming
across the hall mmm dan Murr
my pleasure al thank you gentlemen for
time I am out of town this week and
Nick's reading my notes which i think is
a bit unfair but that's all right
I don't think you need these man it's a
damn tournament I see it
manaman all right why are you holding on
to these you don't need these man this I
have some very big ideas that I don't
want to your brain stop listen to this
thing and start listen to this right so
you can lose everyone's been waiting for
that classic Monday Murrell chemistry
there it is and Dan thank you for being
here in the Mirage on looking forward to
the fun and deciding these movie fights
will be myself and long Dan calling la
arson Daniele Radford and you know
there's uh there's gonna be no polls
today right no there's no polls today
but please keep everything going on
movie fights live we do actually wind up
checking those and all these honestly
you guys have so much fun discussing
with each other and everything it's
great don't don't stop being friends in
our account hell yeah and LAN I have to
point out I enjoy your owl shirt I'm
wearing this owl pin on the day we came
up with this stupid owl [ __ ] that's
right let's say she was born on a day
like today when we both had owl stuff on
hoot-hoot mr. Harris alright so without
further ado so much has changed
oh yes I mean Nick change its constant
JT dropped that cigarette package
[Music]
anytime
thanks door alright so again the first
player to four points wins top two
players after three rounds we'll move on
to the speed round and we start off with
question number one guys we're gonna ask
whatever happened to Sinbad
the comedian question tax issue so we
love Sinbad there's a lot of lore about
Sinbad being confused you know certain
genie movies or whatever but so now we
ask what character should Sinbad play in
Mac reeves Batman reboot if Sinbad were
to play a character in the Batman reboot
that I guess is going to be starring
Robert Pattinson among others who should
Sinbad play Mike start with you okay
well I think there's only one answer to
this I believe that in the new Batman
movie Sinbad should play himself oh my
god okay
he is playing Sinbad in Gotham City and
he is Batman's partner the movie should
be called Batman II and Sinbad okay
there is
Sinbad's origin of courses that he was a
circus boy he was a group called the
flying Sinbad's and there was an
accidents and Sinbad became an orphan
and at that point then Bruce Wayne took
pity on him and brought him into the
fold and he became his partner now
Sinbad doesn't wear a costume
he's just Sinbad mmm-hmm no I'm saying
wears clothes more like a Robin outfit
he doesn't have like a big S on his
chest or anyway he doesn't the
advertising he doesn't need any of that
so he just hangs out with Bruce Wayne
Alda in Batman now quick question I want
to interrupt your opening salvo here yes
you said Sinbad just where's Sinbad
clothes Sinbad a very distinct style are
you gonna give us a taste of what those
Sinbad clothes will be it's uh it's all
neon purple loving it yeah so that's
what he's wearing most of the movie and
at this point it's just like Batman
punches a guy in cinema it's like
yes hell yes and he'll say stuff like
that and he sort of looks like a hype
man
he sort of just like there and he says
funny stuff and like he can do something
formatic upbringing factors in not at
all he didn't do as many of the twists
and stuff he was sort of just on the
ground of the circus a spotter yeah and
he would like I'm the Mike he would do
some of his stand-up in the circus so he
would point out like funny things and
like how a circus is different than a
carnival hence how he survived exactly
cuz he would have been dead if he was
doing it Sindbad playing himself as a
height man we will learn more about that
thank you Mike Carlson Nick that was
really good
hey oh thank you yeah that was was
all right so my suggestion is that
Sinbad plays every character but Batman
but I want to get back to your first
question that you asked
whatever happened to Sinbad yeah yeah so
I'll respond to that with whatever
happened to us as people when did we
stop caring about comedy and and and
triumph and and you know sticking it to
the man but also like representing like
a humanity that was Sinbad you know
Sinbad hasn't been in a movie in 2008
since 2008 yes to those around he has
not been in a movie a feature film a
motion picture since 2008 and fact check
that you know what don't because it's
true I think like some more mirth and
merriment in our life and Sinbad brings
that that's why I want to give Sinbad
the opportunity to be in every role of
Batman because he can tell Batman you
know what hey just being a billionaire
who beats up on Poor's isn't enough he
can tell Batman you know how to really
help the city because Batman's a
stubborn guy he's just not gonna listen
to one person or even two people dressed
up like who look like Sinbad
he needs a whole city so he'll be
playing men women children everyone just
yes it's like Agent Smith and the matrix
I never was
and then the other thing is to like you
have so many Batman reap remakes and
reboots like if this doesn't work you'll
just Warner Brothers already planning
the next one it's just gonna keep
rebooting Lefter itself so why not give
this one a shot mmm right on all right
Sinbad playing the entirety of Gotham
Thank You Nick dan what do you got I
think there's one obvious answer I'm
shocked that Owen said it at least
Catwoman
Sinbad what better way for America to
fall in love with Sinbad again than for
Sinbad to fall in love with Batman this
is not a send bad version of Catwoman he
is playing Catwoman yeah the character
of Catwoman Selina Kyle will be played
by Sinbad this is not he doesn't get
enough credit I don't want to paint him
in a corner of having to be Sinbad this
is a talented man this is a 1997
blockbuster entertainment award winner
for bet for favorite Supporting Actor in
a family no no he knows how to act
he's got range he can stretch I don't
want to just reintroduce America to
Sinbad the man I want to reintroduce
America to Sinbad the actor the
performer this is a great role for him
to be Batman's both foe and friend and
which Sinbad is so much more it's just
not gonna fall in love with some you
know boyish billionaire who just wants
to beat up drug addicts oh no no Selina
Kyle it's a very complicated
relationship
so much past of his past of this role
stakes are very high fight it out here's
the thing why would we want to put
handcuffs on Sinbad and not let him be
Sinbad we all love Sinbad because he's
Sinbad he does his Sinbad thing and all
of the movies we like why would we want
him to be prancing around like a sexy
cat see if that sounds okay but doesn't
sound as good as him making a comedic
observation about a sexy cat I think
only allowing to be citizen bad to be
Sinbad is putting handcuffs on Sinbad
you're saying you're not capable iing
anything but yourself that's ultra
version of Sinbad that's Sinbad prime we
want him at as highest so we wanted his
peak and I'm saying what you're both
saying because everyone's playing Sinbad
or everyone
Sinbad's everyone so all the good points
here are saying and all the good points
you're saying I'm saying them at the
same time can I guess every character
now please yes we'll be Sinbad okay I
want to ask one follow-up question will
Sinbad be like playing a penguin like
this and playing a woman with a more
ladylike voice or is it just they all
are Sinbad's voice well he's an actor so
he's gonna like transform himself into a
role but make it less good that's the
thing like when Paul Rubens is peewee
and then Paul Rubens is the guy who gets
killed in Buffy the Vampire Slayer
it's still Paul Rubens when Paul Rubens
is the hairdresser he deals a lot of
coke and blow he's still Paul Rubens
because he gets performer though Paul
Rubens Sinbad different types of perform
they sell the same sag number what did
they have like they still get paid the
same go okay same for multiple rules
does that no no no and that goes back to
my point about 2008 he hasn't been in a
lot of movies so he's getting paid
parole by the way he's playing the
Pasadena
comedy shop June 28 I think we all once
it we all want Sinbad at this table to
succeed I think that you packed the
movie with so much Sinbad I anything can
get overloaded and I don't want to put
so much Sinbad in the movie that people
get tired of him but before he's even
welcomed back Sinbad overload who would
get my concern though is logistical II
this is to stack Singh of a task force
in bad okay
a movie is hard to make having Sinbad
doing everything motion capture in green
screen the movie is gonna take 15 years
to make and Sinbad is an older gentleman
I don't want him getting too tired I
don't want him getting sick on set it
doesn't
work we don't want to tax Sinbad why is
it handcuffs in bed maybe centenary
breeze to take these parts let him make
that decision okay Sinbad is about
accountability and responsibility and
has Sinbad ever letting you down
no never do it now I feel like he
doesn't have a choice because you can't
go half Sinbad here there either all
Sinbad or none of them are no there's no
half measures you can't have 28 percent
of the denizens of Gotham B Sinbad and
then the other are not so weird it's off
except for Bruce Wayne but but then but
I just think it's too risky it's too
risky a proposition that Sinbad is gonna
say like you know what it's a little too
much you mean I didn't get no Sinbad you
had a good point when if maybe you said
oh he's gonna be Sinbad with all the
characters you can do his voice and you
can do jokes Penguins gonna do some
observational humor Catwoman's gonna do
observational humor but you're saying no
he's gonna try to like do a voice I
didn't say he's looking like my movie
has grade-a Sinbad the best Sinbad you
would want the run for your mount final
final sauce okay I so 20 minutes Bruce
Wayne into stand up all right he talks
Bruce Wayne and they go out and do the
clubs this is gonna be a different
Batman movie in general we're not gonna
have this thing we've seen so much
Batman lately Bruce gonna joke about
like hey what do you call like a couple
of dead parents like not going to
therapies no that's not a great joke
just like Bruce is gonna make know he's
cooked Sinbad will teach him how to be
his he Bruce will teach Sinbad the ways
of Batman and Sinbad will teach him how
to make an observation about and this is
a real Sinbad joke
how Fahrenheit is a better way to
measure temperature than Celsius that's
a real Sinbad joke look it up he'll
teach Bruce about that so he'll be fine
to that joke I believe he said
Fahrenheit is it translates to or no
excuse me he it was Celsius translates
Duke should have been Fahrenheit I
believe that's the punch line of the
joke if I wrote a very good joke it's a
very good joke and he's going to teach
Bruce how to do that we're gonna get
different levels we're gonna get
different stuff that you've never seen
in this before and it's gonna be the
exact right amount of Sinbad and he's
going to be firing on all cylinders and
he's gonna be himself which is what we
want to see thank you Mike Carlson Nick
Mundy
2008 2009 2010 2011 2012 2013 you can
see where this is going 2014 2015 2016
2017 2018 in those years there has not
been a Sinbad movie as far as I know I
think it's high time Sinbad's in one of
the biggest movies of all time until the
next reboot and he plays all the
characters except for Batman because
Batman needs something different we've
seen sad Batman we've seen angry bad met
Batman we've seen campy Batman but we
haven't seen a Batman with just all
Sinbad I'm done talking thanks Nick damn
yeah this is a Sinbad for a new
generation and when you look at the
character of Catwoman what does Catwoman
in Batman's life she's a spark of
intrigue she's barking joy she is she
sees she breathes new life she makes
Batman see a new side to the world of
criminals and and who better to bring
that element into the bat universe than
Sinbad the people that love him already
love him he's gonna win over a whole new
generation of fans III don't think that
he I want to challenge him I want to
give Sinbad room to to expand beyond
what we know and to grow into something
that we don't and I think if he's
himself we know that we love Sinbad it
doesn't give us an opportunity to learn
anything new about him with with all
Sinbad I think it's a very risky
proposition either it's too daunting for
him just on a physical taxing level or I
don't want the audience to be in a
position where they have Sinbad overload
I think that my pick is the right use of
Sinbad it's the right amount of Sinbad
it's the Sinbad the world needs and
Sinbad the world once Dan one would say
doing a whole episodes featuring Dan
Morel in every episode would be too much
not me
but alright let's go to the facts own
sponsored by Circuit City lon
what's going on factually I think I hate
to poke a big hole in one of our
fighters arguments with Simba provided
the voice of Roper in Pixar's planes
that was released theatrically in 2013
appearance of Simba
but still the film appears it is true as
last live-action appearance at a film
was as Benny in cutting the mustard and
that was in 2008 all the other factor
checks in bed will be at the canyon in
Agoura Hills on June 29 and Pasadena's
the Rose on Friday July 12
check out those shows fantastic long
stellar job appreciated okay right - you
bet high the stakes are very high the
answers are and we're on point very
tough to decide so I think we should
give a three-way tie but you know we
don't do that here so let's break it
down so people didn't you oh no it's not
the last episode alright so Mike
explains Mike I think we could have had
a little bit more fun with describing
Sinbad's outfits because he wears some
wonderful billowy pants I would just
like to know maybe look could give me a
little bit more there there was
lightning bolts right on great Gregor
great dad I feel like we could have
heard more about that like I love that
it's this choice of Catwoman but I
thought we could have broken down
Sinbad's take on it and like felt a
little bit more of the Sinbad and Nick I
think maybe they didn't get a little bit
with like our what could we be in danger
of Sinbad overload and then I started
thinking like okay am I gonna see a sea
of Sinbad's all over Gotham who's I
don't know it was a little unwieldy for
me to picture although also delightful
potentially I mean as Catwoman is
delightful but I thought Mike really at
the end of the day fit that peg in the
correct hole was just like you know
Sinbad being Sinbad and being up a
height
for Batman would be ridiculous and fun
and I wouldn't mind seeing a scene where
Bruce Willis does Bruce Willis Bruce
Wayne without her I like to see Bruce
Willis do a tight five but Bruce Wayne
do a tight five out the clothes with
Sinbad so I'm going Mike Carlson on this
one well what do we got first Wilson the
new Bevan I hope so Sinbad Virginia's
yeah yeah I largely agree I thought that
all three were you know funny ideas I
got a good sense of all of what the
movies would be like but I really
thought Mike I kind of the killer
argument with in all of Sinbad's
greatest roles your first kids your
jingles all the way your houseguests
he's kind of playing a version of Simba
and I want to totally hide the Sinbad
that's what the people want ultimately I
was kind of one over by that I'm also
going with Mike boom
Mike you're gonna get that point
Danielle I would love to hear your
thoughts though uh you know honestly I'd
completely agree with both of you I do
think that Sinbad is that his best when
he's just being Sinbad like you said he
don't want to hide the Sinbad we were we
were bereft of Sinbad for far too long
while the Bahamas got what we couldn't
have so I think that what people really
want is they want to see one good role
of Sinbad's being Sinbad heck yeah oh
really
ears are burning right by the way check
out Sinbad in the seven seas Ray
Harryhausen has some good models and
that's some good one 1950s 1960s that
does not feature the comedian no does
not feature the convenience it's about
then oh yes Byron's about a pirate dude
fighting cyclopses looking at my notes
just as a new city
this will reveal itself later all right
that was good times Mike is up 1 to
Nilsson nil Nick and Dan looking to get
on the board so we ask question number
two galaxies edge you've been there
right I've been there three times what
signs yes real or really oh wow
I know people haven't been there at all
well they slept on a day they should
have gotten reservation yeah so we asked
independent film should get its own land
at Disneyland a la galaxy's edge and we
start off with player number two for
question number two mr. Nick Mundy look
if galaxy's edge taught us anything it's
that people love exclusive amusement
parks people have written articles have
they stay there for four days and it's
changed their life how it's a religious
experience but you know what it needs
something
another thing that's happening is like
you know maybe the environments not
great right now and people are are
caring about it as much as maybe they
are caring about getting into amusement
parks so I want to take that exclusivity
like exclusivity and like really try to
get people super excited for a great
amusement park that helps save the world
and that's why I want to build an
amusement park base on an inconvenient
truth Al Gore's documentary about the
world burning so you get all these lines
you get people ready to go lines and
lines all over the game all over the
world right people came to a galaxy's
edge I believe so yes and you get them
in line ready to see what they think is
going to be the most fantastical
monumental amusement park ever and then
they get into a room and someone plays a
VHS tape and explains why the world's
burning and I think that might be the
only way to get through to people gotcha
at all all right to save the world we're
gonna build an amusement park
all right snickering people to make them
think they're going to amusement park
but it's actually going to be a
videotape in a conference
yep all right thank you Nick dan what do
you got I think that the land has to be
the full immersive experience to give
you the essence not just the movie but
the overall feel of the entire the
entirety of a franchise or a movie and
that's why I think the obvious choice
which is being John Malkovich Being John
Malkovich the land
well of course have the the the
centerpiece attraction the ride much
like Star Wars smugglers run will be
John Malkovich adventures through time
and again much like smugglers writing
you will have different adventures that
you can take there's the Cyrus the virus
chase down the Las Vegas Strip you are
as always this is a POV ride you are
John Malkovich it's also co-op so you
have four people inside John Malkovich
is head you can control his actions to
help him get through these different
moments through his career there's the
the Las Vegas Strip chase from Conair of
course you've got the Dangerous Liaisons
seduction with Michelle Pfeiffer where
you must successfully seduce Michelle
Pfeiffer and then you've got Teddy KGB's
high-stakes Hold'em tournament against
Matt Damon from rounders you never know
which one you're gonna get so that's
gonna drive repeat people under those
rides but it's not just one ride it's a
land right that's what we're looking for
it's an entire land you have roaming
Malkovich's throughout Malkovich's are
walking around interacting as john
malkovich with the guests which if
you're in john malkovich land is
something i think you're gonna be
interested in plus as somebody that's
going to be in this demographic
eventually it is a great resource for
bald men and their 60s to find work I
think that this is this could be a real
boon side side you've got the haul of
John's much like the Hall of Presidents
where you have mini-me John Malkovich
characters animatronic Lee Sang lines
like you know I see you standing over
the grave of another dead president all
of the great John Malkovich is in the
line of fire yeah Eastwood you've got
the Merton Fleming you can go take a
picture a tattoo or the seventh and a
half floors you're drowns down drinking
coffee there's the theme restaurant buck
Howard's
which serves a lot of themed foods
you've got the of mice and mint julep
that's the signature cocktail there
you have the heartburn after eating
jalapeno burger and then the the Art
School Confidential that's the the
custom artisanal ice cream that's made
there on set and then it wouldn't be a
land unless you had a 200 dollar memento
that you could take home that's gonna be
the customized puppet shop a Mike I know
you're gonna like this where you can you
can make your own a bunch of Being John
Malkovich type marionettes customized of
course to your specifications that you
can then walk out of the park with you
as you go I think it captures the
essence of not just the film but John
Malkovich as a man and as a career and I
think it's gonna be a great time at the
park for the whole family
all right Dan coming through with layers
of details and merch for John Malkovich
the lab being try them out which to the
land might very good yes very good
here's the thing most people don't maybe
not they don't know this about me I'm a
very cautious person I'm not a person
who takes drugs I don't to do anything
wild believe it or not I'm not that type
of person but sometimes I think wouldn't
it be fun to take some drugs wouldn't it
be fun to get on the back of a hog and
go out then see America in a trippy
weird way but of course I won't do that
because I play it safe you're a good boy
I'm a very good boy yes that is a
hundred percent but what if there was a
place what if there was an immersive
land where I could enjoy the things I'm
saying but in a safe way
yes I'm of course talking about creating
a land based on the 1969 independent
film Easy Rider there it is Dennis
Hopper Peter Fonda iconic road movie
drug movie two scumbags driving across
the America picking up other scumbags
and this is this experience will take
all of us who are good people good boy
nothing to see you're bad if you take
drugs I'm just saying like playing it
safe type folks we will immediately get
into the land and we will be given new
innovative LSD goggles
these are goggles that will let us
SaLuSa Nate and simulate what's going on
if you're actually taking a trip but you
will not be high you will not be
actually you could take them off at any
time
don't worry about it you'll be safe then
it will be a ride where you will get on
a motorcycle it of course on a track
don't worry it is not a real motorcycle
and you will pick up a drunken ACLU
lawyer on the way he will jump on to the
motorcycle but don't worry just a
college student ok he's not a real
drunken ACLU lawyer okay Asha you were
gonna go on a trip II weird fun ride
you're gonna walk around the desert but
there's gonna be fun
giant hallucination there's gonna be
giant animal a giant snake that comes at
you but don't worry the snake is a robot
okay
this is just a little bit about what
you're gonna see and you're gonna enjoy
at this Disneyland attraction Easy Rider
as I call it Easy Rider land Easy Rider
that's an innovative way to say it yeah
sure thing fight it out fellas
Nick you've essentially described Epcot
Center as it exists currently I take it
away my Epcot Center is a wonderful
place where you can learn about the land
you can learn about aggro call agro
business and agriculture is coming you
can learn about going to space what you
can push buttons like astronauts do you
can learn I'll just push your buttons
are gonna happen spaceship earth you can
see a slow moving robot of Leonardo da
Michelangelo painting the Sistine Chapel
Epcot Center is a treasure
not to mention World Showcase is a great
place to drink trial I'm so sorry I got
really worked up sure I would just like
to point out this is a trap because this
just shows that we currently have a
theme park that appreciate that it
teaches you to appreciate the earth
without trapping tourists inside of a
conference room and making them watch of
vaa vaa first of all I don't think they
even made an immunity truth on VHS and
if they did I don't know where you could
find that line you may have to
fact-check for me the Imagineers can do
anything that they put their minds to
but why would they put their mind to
that I feel like there are so many more
imaginative ways to get your point
across than like your opening day it's a
one-day Pony your opening day you're
gonna get people there and then the
person's like Mike who seek out these
newer times will be upset will be
I wear very yeah I have a failure it's
gonna be super exclusive and it's gonna
get people at a time and they're gonna
blow their minds with how fatal the
planet is right right now world - make a
whole world like why actually just make
like a bunch of like icy icebergs
melting there could be a cool dark ride
where like icebergs melt it's true it's
gonna take a lot of pollution to build
that ride
whereas this just cuts out the middleman
shows everyone weird up things are can I
ask where are the lands in Disney
because Disney Land are they in
California Adventure are they in Disney
owned are they in Orlando where where
are you we were about the cars world
what that Sun but I do a tour Springs
race or one of the best dark rides I
know I love it but like we have to start
making sacrifices also dan dan real
quick yeah this the question was what
independent film yes should get it tell
him yes so Connor was an independent
film round richland the movie the movie
itself is about going into the mind and
the eyes of John Malkovich so the movie
is based around the John Malkovich
experience which encompasses his other
works okay
sure sure sure but do we need to idolize
another liberal elite world hmm
that the planet is agnostic when it
comes to politics now here's my Gore
elite and liberal here's my problem and
Dan did a really great job but here's my
problem with it mine is a truly new
experience that you cannot get anywhere
else at Disneyland he's essentially
pitching what there was an up caught
ride called cranium command where a
little robot boy named buzzy was inside
of a human head and you would see all
what was going on you would see from his
perspective it's very similar to that he
also compared someone in Falcon which if
it's like a hybrid of those two that's
interesting but I see Cameron Poe on the
Las Vegas Strip because I don't think
every right you know
rides mic it's all about the concept
behind zero and three I think maybe five
maybe five six and then there's
innovative things happening all time I'm
just saying yours feels - you can get a
similar experience two things before I'm
just saying Mike - I can drop acid go to
the desert and do your thing for like a
tenth of the cost but but it will
changer as' it's dangerous and I
wouldn't do that might get out there and
live a little bit I would encourage
people anyone out there do not get out
there and live a little it's so
dangerous it's unsafe Mike
mice chair sinking like the world
sinking if you don't go into the
inconvenient truth right now Mike yes
sir you're trying to build a ride that
experiences danger but not actually put
you in danger that's right yes but if
you put on acid goggles you still might
trip and you might fall you might be
division yeah it's altering your senses
what if I put those goggles on I like it
gate man I got more I want more of that
and I can't afford to go back -
distantly what am I gonna do I'm gonna
hire is be all the time you gave me the
taste Mike here's a higher and
experience though with better goggles so
if you like it you just get you upgraded
this better hold on make your point and
then roll it into your final thoughts
Mike I think you're either Easy Rider
ride is too dangerous for you I don't
think you would like it there's not
enough there's no puppets hmm there's no
it's a little dangerous it feels like
more of a Six Flags ride which the
ultimate insult yeah feels like a Six
Flags ride my ride is a room with the
VHS tape playing a movie that we should
all watch and we're all gonna get in
lines and we're all gonna write articles
about it we're all gonna appreciate it
and it's gonna be exclusive and this is
a bad idea but it's a bad idea that the
world needs also Dan's movies just
filled with studio films thanks Nick dan
I see your point about the the resources
of always spending it with building a
LAN but sometimes you got to spend
carbon to save carbon and I think that
if you want to get the point across and
in community truth it's probably one
over as many people as it are he's gonna
you're gonna turn people off of that
whole thing it's just to low stakes it's
not even a land it's a room you pitched
a room you pitched a movie theater
essentially Mike again yours is is more
of like and it's an experience but if
it's an experience that I understand the
safe playing it safe angle but at the
same time I feel like you can replicate
it you can do this elsewhere like first
of all not only did I pitch something
that you cannot replicate in the real
world there's no actual way for you to
go inside of John Malkovich's head and
experience these things from a
first-hand point of view and again I
cannot recommend the food about cowards
enough particularly the Art School
Confidential that is going to be really
spectacular spared no expense but but
more than that I actually pitched a land
my might what I am building is not just
one ride or sort of built off of a kind
of experience this is a fully immersive
360-degree immersion into the world of
Being John Malkovich in the world of
John Malkovich himself and that's what
you want when you build a land it's not
just a ride kind of based around the
loose theme everywhere you turn you're
going to be living in this world and I
think that's what you need in these big
themed lands thank you dan Moreau Mike
look there if there's food in my land as
well who's a diner and the food's very
good they're not in mine okay
there's no food and I'm just saying that
look kids like motorcycles kids love
Dennis Hopper and if you're thinking
kids motorcycles on hopper they're gonna
be Malkovich every time I don't even
know I don't have to say I would use
hopper over Malkovich time all right lon
come on down with those facts and also
please chime in with your thoughts on
this yesterday Inconvenient Truth was
released on vehicle
in 2006 I could not find a current copy
for sale it's actually quite
sought-after in VHS collector community
apparently I feel mr. Mann
Audrey my only other note was called the
Easy Rider gangs a comedian not such bad
guy the better that wasn't fun I was
saying like I get scumbag scopa charge
the point of the whole oh it was like
they were embracing freedom meant that
in a good way just come back to druggie
scumbags did the Easy Rider pitch but I
thought damn dinged my pretty good on me
it kind of could be a gateway drug to
Dewey doing more drugs if you go to Easy
Rider land and you love it what's to
stop you from doing your own cocaine
deal is taking off across the country
next I you know such an important topic
but I felt like you could have done more
to make it a little bit more appealing
so it doesn't seem so much like
punishment for the audience like why not
an animatronic Al Gore giving an
interaction citation of carbon so
ultimately I thought the person with the
most fleshed out pitch the the best
overall idea for land that I could
really see happening was dance I'm going
dance great Danielle do you want to
chime in on this yeah I have to agree
with with Mike's Mike's it's a great
concept but it sounds like something
that could be done in a or VR where you
talk about the glasses plus the only way
to do drugs is drugs man don't do drugs
but the only way to do drugs is to do
drugs um Nick I love yours but that
feels like one of those Shia LeBoeuf
stunts where people wait in line forever
then you get there then it's just Shia
LaBeouf saying like Beck's at UK just
comes out of yells at you by the earth
yeah what it's fair and people would
definitely enjoy that but no been there
done that
video profiting off such thing yeah this
right do we've done we've done some more
regrettable video on a personal yet for
dams it was I felt like he had a very
clear idea of what he wanted to do with
this land he had he gave me all the good
pun food names that I'm gonna be missing
when the good place goes off the air and
then he had that really good dinger
which sealed it for me was when he
mentioned that essentially what Nick was
pitching was a movie theater so I gotta
go to him yeah Dan you get the point of
their seats though so how can it be a
movie theater the it has already been
decided sorry Nick also but I doing what
one great in unintentional point from
Dan he was talking about how Mike's Park
might be a gateway and then it was such
a gateway that it caused damage the
f-bomb
this really isn't weird fights you guys
yes because I always look over when any
contestant drops an f-bomb Dan's like
there goes our monetization I care about
those kids how that are gonna go it's
Easy Rider land and and just drop acid
every day for the rest of their lives
yeah don't those wee little movie
fighters yes indeed all right there are
35 okay so Mike with one point Nick
looking to get on the board Dan Taylor
leave and Dan with one point and we go
to question number three so we asked
what non MCU movie franchise should get
22 films and then a big team up movie
where the characters all travel through
time man so much to choose from we're
gonna start with Dan thank you for
asking how and I guess there's only one
answer to this question and that is
Richard Linklater's before series which
already is in its own way a time travel
experiment we were gonna have to up the
production every nine years it's not
gonna work with the natural lifespans
of Ethan Hawke and Julie Delpy as we
know them
so we're gonna have to up the production
a little bit but I think what we're
missing a little bit is with these films
is what are we building to here it's
been very nice to visit these in this
couple throughout their lives three
times now but let's send them on an
adventure they've talked enough it's
time for a little bit of action so yes
we're gonna do a series of films in
which they fill various roles as we know
Ethan Hawke's character is a writer this
will be discovered as a as a cover it'll
be more of a mr. and mrs. Smith
situation where they go on various
adventures leading up to an
extinction-level event that happens in
the twenty first movie the twenty second
movie will be called after extinction
all the others will have before and an
after extinction they will have to go
back in time to prevent the extinction
event which happened which as it turns
out the key to that is Adam Goldberg who
if you oh I'm sure you remember and
before sunrise was uncredited as man
sleeping on train and it turns out that
that was planted in the film back in
1995 by Richard Linklater he is a
scientist who was researching the very
problem that swallowed up the earth they
need to go back and save this scientist
prevent the Earth from being destroyed
and in the process we discover each
other alright Dan coming in with those
before trilogy deep cuts thank you Mike
avatar great thank you thank you that's
fine I mean everyone knows I one a
little bit more alright folks we know
avatar it's got a rich rich bunch of
characters a rich story and this is
something we want to see we know we're
already gonna get you know a real world
we're getting what four or five how many
of these are we getting something like
Central shield a bark shield above our
waters of gods all the seeds of the
tears is one of them as well but in my
were in my reality tears of the Sun
kingdom of heaven in my reality home
Tree of Life
golden child and then this one just
called the child it's very confusing
it's very I think we need to spin out
all the characters though in their own
different movies I want a three-part
jakesully of course the hero we all know
his name Jake Sully the main character
out of Avatar I want us to do a three
part three different movies called Sully
stories he's an older gentleman now he's
telling stories from his life being an
avatar okay I want a movie about dr.
grace Augustine we remember her name
Sigourney Weaver's character okay now
this is gonna be I'm gonna take a little
bit of a left turn this is a Disney Plus
series seven seasons it's called dr.
grace under fire okay it's just about
her practice like I want to do different
genres here I don't the overt says those
aren't films them that's fine with me I
agree with Steven Spielberg he's a
genius
Colonel miles Klaw rich we all remember
his name Stephen Lang a trilogy of film
called baby miles how did this baby get
so angry and why did he eventually
joined the military and become such a
mean man we're gonna explore it it takes
place from when he was 120 was three so
each movie is a different year of his
baby childhood Parker Selfridge we
remember that name that's of course
Giovanni Ribisi he was going for the
unobtanium okay this is another Disney
Plus series called Parker Selfridge
can't lose at seven seasons and then of
course James Patrick pants famous role
of shuttle pilot three different movies
called shuttle pilot and of course
there'll be three other movies starring
Sean Patrick Murphy's character Cohutta
pilot three different clothes shuttle
pilot movies I think we're gonna take
and we're gonna finally finally dig into
these characters that we know so much is
underneath the circuit service and then
of course is all gonna culminate in the
movie where they all travel back in time
and help during World War Two okay so
one follow-up question I had mentioned
no movies about the Navi the well to me
I the human characters really when I
connect so there's still like 10 movies
left in the slate okay and that can be
all the night is
and pro not like killing the World Tree
well I was certainly uh hold on I was
very much sympathetic to Colonel miles
Quaritch yes they're true oh but they'll
be Jake Sully is a Navi he becomes fully
in obviously there will be certainly
some Navi in his story right Nick what
do you got
everyone loves live-action Disney remake
movies from Beauty and the Beast to
Jungle Book to Aladdin
these movies are perfect in every single
way and they're great and they're
necessary and it's important we watch
them and it's important that like we
keep making them over and over again
because they're so good and important
and we're like halfway through three of
these movies I've already come out this
year one might be coming out this
weekend
we don't even know like Dumbo came out
did you know that damn I did I reviewed
it well yeah was it great no well there
is maybe that's just your bias because
they're all great because they make us
remember the movies that we used to
watch before and then we're like oh yeah
this movie so we're already like halfway
through the 22 films we only have to
make 11 more in the next couple of weeks
Hercules Mulan Snow White other Disney
movies Bambi Bambi is gonna be great Jon
Favreau can direct it eat either Jon
fabric and directed it doesn't matter as
long as it reminds us of what it was and
so when they get together in the big 22
like big climactic movie with all these
live-action characters they can go back
in time and then start making the
musicals and Broadway and remake the
movies again and then when they get to
the 22nd one and that one they can go
back in time and make new and it mated
versions so it's just gonna keep driving
profits to Disney and it's gonna be
self-perpetuating
and that's why this is the franchise
that will not only be the best but it
will actually do it because Dan the only
way the before movie
I'm so confused I have so many questions
the only way let's open it up go ahead I
don't so in the twenty second movie they
all the characters team up and go back
and go back in time and make Disney
musicals in but it's a movie about them
remaking Disney music yep but you're
still gonna pay it wait so what time
period did they go to do they go back to
like when Walt Disney was alive or
became CEO okay so they go back and they
also Aladdin is talking to Bob Iger and
he and Bob iger's like I'd like to cast
you on the role of let's say the beast
and beauty and the beat yes it's yeah
it's just gonna be self-perpetuating so
like and then like yah go he goes oh yah
go I'd like you to play one of the
rescuers down under yeah that's gonna be
a movie that we're gonna see it's gonna
be great so but then do they go out and
make more movies there's that first they
make the musicals again and then they
make new animated movies and then they
make new animated live-action reboots so
this isn't a question like one property
these are like many property this is all
how is this even legal it's why Disney
man that's the new thing but I should
just say live-action Warner Brothers or
something yeah but they're not they're
not re twelve movies in but this is
there's not a cinematic universe maybe
you'd have a point if this was cinematic
pitching the live-action remakes of
animated Disney film right but it's 22
separate movies right they're all
connected because they're not affected
there's no like how good they are on
that inside the movie they're making
movies which making musicals for making
music
animations which
in a movie about making musicals - is
you're not gonna see Bambi Catholic
singing in the rain is it like singing
it or no it's like uh it's another I'm
trying to think of I this is all being
you know you know it's not confusing
how much box office it's gonna make it's
gonna make a ton of money true I don't
disagree with that and that's worth it
and here's a problem with the before
movies you have to wait nine years I
just didn't math it's gonna be at least
171 years to finish your friend listen
to me no I volunteered League later
doesn't work that way clear Linklater
Linklater likes nothing more than to
challenge himself he loves to challenge
himself in his filmmaking and what is
more challenging than taking these
stories that he's used to telling us so
that's what he does he takes a story
that she's used to telling a certain way
and it tells it in a new way it's this
is like boyhood reversed into five days
to make I don't buy that Ethan Hawke's
character it lives a fantastical crazy
life because in the last one he could
barely make time to go see his son Hank
because because we haven't seen what's
happening in those eight years you don't
know what happened in the in the moment
before this is what's happening in
between those nine years and this is why
this is such a rich thematic depth for
us to cover is we also have missing gaps
in time between these movies that we can
spend movies sequentially filling in so
that by the time you get to that you'll
have this rich tapestry of just why he
didn't make that plain it feels to them
before something it feels totally
inconsistent though we like the talking
that's what we like about these movies
we don't want fantastical stuff and
these these grounds get a little like
I'm a crab boiling in water what do you
mean and I like I I'm just you're gonna
notice you're gonna say what's this
weird stuff in these in these nice
movies I'm not gonna do some we're
correct by the way
you know who I was talking about woman
it's not gonna put up with this Julie
Delpy will absolutely put up with it it
is a new challenge and that's what
Richard Linklater does it tell baby
Julie to hell by Julie Delpy that's a
silly final thoughts we have plenty of
time this is tape sure you know what
Nick thank you for that Mike go ahead
and lay something out for us and then
shortly thereafter Ole Miss Dynel thigh
avatar my beloved avatar the only one
that is an actual full universe there
was a Cirque de Soleil show that I went
not that I want to see it's staple
center called toruk they have theme
parks this is the full thing this is a
thing that's already it's tailor-made to
make so many different movies which is
why they're making so many movies
already I think honestly just tacking on
15 more is not gonna be that different
we're already getting five we're
probably gonna get 15 if these are a hit
he has a second one he's making five
movies at once they're making them all
once right now in a lab somewhere and
they're gonna be the biggest don't count
against James Camrys a maniac who always
wins
he always wins dan start us off with the
final thoughts sure yeah well as you
said avatar it's not that different from
what we're already getting and whereas
we as far as I know Richard Linklater
does not have plans to do 19 more before
movies culminating in a world saving
time travel and adventure heist with
Adam Goldberg that's what I want to see
I don't want to see the Avatar cycle
said I'm are you gonna get plus they
going back to stop World War two like
can the Navi even breathe on really no
that was Mike's that was my travel back
in time to stop Cameron actually like it
said rain especially but I just I just
don't see that if it's ever go back it's
time to save their own planet or to save
the home tree or something but the the
practicality of the Navi when coming to
earth I don't understand Plus Disney
Plus series you have to you have to have
six seven different different Disney
Plus series and it's a big financial ask
from consumers you're not asking to
watch ten movies you're also scholars a
monthly subscription hey you can't miss
this one you got it's everything wrong
it's everything
wrong with it with moviemaking today you
gotta watch it in 14 different places
minor are thematic they're sequential
you can go see them in the theater you
want to do it at Richard Linklater he
built this he can change it into what he
wants to now I want to see him take it
in a different way yours Nick I don't
even get I don't even understand it's
it's the the there's they're completely
and disconnected films and then they're
going back in the movies about making
different movies but not the movie it's
completely it's nonsensical and I felt a
sense I don't understand any of it and I
don't think people would be that
interested in it people are very
interested in the lion king and alladin
and be where movies have to make a
hundred two hundred million dollars to
break even yeah well I need to make like
ten fifteen million my movies don't even
pay the original right right Mike let's
hear your final I think it's him we go
around this way did I give my handle
thoughts I mean you did give a give me
more I'll get more
whatever you kind of chair you want to
put on top of your own yo if my reality
takes place which I believe it will yes
in thirty years you will look at the top
box office grosses of all time and it
will be all avatar all the movies will
be avatar because James Cameron's
director all of them and again James
Cameron does not lose and let's also say
the greatest movie beast of all time
will be in every movie that will tie
them all together the mighty Acron aka
the banshee I've ridden on the back of
the mighty Akron and this is the most
glorious beast people are in love with
this thing they buy toys of it this is
going to tie everything together yeah
the mighty Acron jakesully st.
stand out standing we all remember that
line of course and then the thing is
with with world war ii ma I'm just sort
of putting the question out there
wouldn't it be interesting if the war
was won faster who knows lundi the
greatest beast of them all is nostalgia
and Disney feeds it mightily and these
movies are going to happen they're
happening now like they're Disney's
about to announce a bunch of them and
they're easy to make they don't have to
pay the original writers they just use
the old scripts they even cast the same
characters because that's what we want
as a market we just want the same thing
slightly different and we're getting
and we're going to it and there's gonna
be 11 more and then they're gonna go
back and make some musicals of it and
then they'll take those musicals and
make some animated musicals about it and
then take those animated musicals and
make more live-action movies and the
profit is gonna keep churning man then
we're gonna get all the money and you
sir
I love you but I want to watch those
people grow old julia Delfy and Ethan
Hawke he's an entourage
all right take us to the fact zone Ethan
Hawke and Julie Delpy thank you as well
we have 4 avatar films already on the
way their titles are avatar the way of
water avatar the sea bear avatar the
tolkien Raider and the quest for a WA
the quest for a WA a ey W n this brain
is just bubbling with oxygen and the
Cirque du Soleil show is called torrid :
the first flight so far this year we've
only had two Disney live-action remakes
come out those are Dumbo and Aladdin a
third Lion King thank you in theaters on
July 19th and we had a bunch of engines
of the rescuers down under you can just
say the rescuers it's the same two mice
they are Bernard and Bianca Thank You
lon
Danielle would you please weigh in on
this colossal debate boy I can't all
right so all of these you know Mike I
loved your arguments I don't know that
they're gonna be able to support all of
these different shows on on Disney Plus
I understand what you were talking about
but I don't the series III don't know
that people want to know as much about
the gutter I don't know think people
want to know as much about all these
peripheral characters people are still
debating on if they want like how much
we're gonna want more avatars and Nick
moody I love you I have no idea any of
the words that you said I know them all
individually but I
when you put them together in that order
again what you're talking about when
you're saying you want we want the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over again but when it came to the
time-travel stuff that confused me I do
wish that we could go back in time and
time travel and pay some of the original
screenwriters some of that money but
that's neither here nor there you don't
deserve it right Thank You Danielle yeah
this was three very different
fascinating explorations here Nick I
really like I like this like meta take
of like going back and seeing them make
these musicals after like just the
evolution so I'm intrigued there I'm
very enjoy yeah I gotta get that money
and Dan it seemed like the tonal shift
like I think Mike pointed out that that
could be a little herky-jerky oh yeah
Danielle really now just hmm is the
thirst for the interest in the all these
tertiary characters going to be there
Mike to support this journey I'm uh you
know what I'm Nick's Nick's vision like
will there be a live act will Bob Iger
or a character playing bah got Bob Iger
be in there yeah all right
just the whole that meta element of them
making the musicals after and that
exploration of breaking down this
money-making behemoth some of the
live-action you know what Nick you made
us think but you get my point as well
hahaha for this weird journey itself
reflexive meta Disney journey long one
for Dan one for Nick yes it's a tie then
we can do more nonsense yeah I mean
honestly I remember if you don't tie it
we don't have to do more nice
I felt like to me I thought a lot of
what Nick was saying was interesting but
I felt like he just didn't I didn't get
a clear enough vision of what these
movies would actually be and that's what
I really want exactly what they were
sadly I don't think that I can put
Victor so it really came down to Mike
versus Dan for me I might actually have
the better more coherent pitch for what
all of these various projects would be
but I actually think that kind of cuts
against him because the more you talk
about it the more I was like hey I don't
think we need three movies about that
guy I don't think we need three movies
about that character maybe a little more
limited the Avatar world than he
initially had presented so yeah I'm also
gonna go with Dan and be before leek
later series boom Dan you get that point
[Music]
good stuff so Dan and Mike moving the
speed around Nick look you're gonna be
sorry when we get the 22nd Disney movie
I mean that's gonna happen I mean you
know what now you may be uh you may have
the last laugh on that one I do not
doubt it Nick funny stuff interesting
points all around and thank you for
warning us about climate change but
let's jump into the speed round it's two
for Dan one for Mike and Nick I'll
probably come to you and you know just -
yeah I think thanks man
all right here's question one that's
Pedro and again I ask questions shout
out your answers 20 second to elaborate
and then ten second rebuttals in the
order that you answered which group
would inspire better Oscar bait musical
biopic by Lee myung-bak by bio bio
medical procedure can you repeat the
question
yes and they're going to be two choices
foreign gotta go which group would
inspire the better Oscar mate musical
biopic Limp Bizkit or Smash Mouth limp
Biskit okay
Smash Mouth alright we heard Mike we
heard Mike with limp Biskit first Dan
will follow up with Smash Mouth in a
moment Mike twenty seconds begin when
you speak Smash Brothers to save lupus
like crazy they had a whole like fred
durst in the late 90s he was like datin
Britney Spears he was going on weird
things hanging out with Marilyn Manson
this is some crazy journey this man has
said smash mothers fun they're at state
fairs but who cares live biscuit
that's gritty West Berlin that's freaky
make up that's it's gonna be an awesome
visual when we're talking about a movie
like let's let's think about also just
time but where's the depth Michael and
biscuit Fred Durst is a movie director
now with biscuit was popular and then
everyone else went on to be popular but
Smash Mouth was huge and then there were
a joke and now they're huge again a
whole new generation discovered of
that's the biopic that's the rise and
fall and rise of a band that's what
makes a good movie they were cool then
they weren't and now they're cool again
that's great Limp Bizkit system come on
stock starfish no thank you a Fred Durst
he is a multi-talented multi-hyphenate
okay he has a jazz club he is a director
that makes it more than that Steven
what's his name from smash mo
I like the Smash Mouth but they're not
as interesting or as weird as them I
give me corn give me monkey and head and
all those guys they were the biscuit
their their husbands and no one cares I
want to rise to follow the rise I want a
good band that's that has sit in first
city on what's wrong I am chord get get
the hell out of here with [ __ ] you
know what this has been a great walk
down 90's memories in the lame but yeah
just because um Mike you got a little
bit more specific than some of the
points of what Fred Durst was up to in
the 90s and some of the things we could
see where his dad smoking a little more
general terms about his band so because
of that you you were a little more vivid
I'm going the mic with limpa Smash Mouth
tried to capitalize on Carrie Fisher's
death oh my god what is that a tweet
that was like yeah she was a big Smash
Mouth fan what she was a big Smash Mouth
engine not maybe she was I mean Justin
Bieber said and Frank would have been a
believer
blonde what do you like on this both
great arguments for a really crazy silly
question so props all around but yeah I
agree I feel like I like dance point
about the rise father and the rise again
but I feel like Mike took this on more
of a journey of here's the story of limp
Biskit it's got all these rises and
falls more dramatic so yeah I'm going
with Mike as well Oh Mike great moment
in sports you just tie it up movie
fights here with Orleans shout out to
corn sucks
damn Nick coming for the new metal bands
today alright vicious question number
two we're tied up to two after
homecoming and far from home what should
they call the inevitable third
spider-man film Hometown Buffet they
walked into that homies homies zombies
all right great
we heard Hometown Buffet first Dan
you'll be second Mike 22nd three when
you speak we have to do something
different like these films so Norman
Osborn takes over the Hometown Buffet
franchise this is that this is going to
be the thing that leads to the next big
crossover event and now the whole time'
face are evil across the country
spider-man has to go inside the home
town buffets beat a shocker electro all
of the bad guys and beat Norman Osborn
this is yes as a tie-in with Hometown
Buffet but they're getting a lot of
money we that would be financed because
of it because we're getting so much this
is Disney here they could think there
had to go home they could Golden Corral
at worst they don't have to go home
towns up they just to stick with the
naming convention no I think you can
have homies and it's not just about
spider-man we've seen two about
spider-man let's have more of his
friends let's have more of him being
cool with people and making new friends
not just another Norman Osborn in
another fighting Super Bowl maybe
that'll be the third one people get sick
of it let's expand the spider-verse
we've never seen a fight in a buffet
before in a spider
as friends there - in the Hometown
Buffet as well so we're gonna get our
homies and we're gonna get a weird
buffet fight that's gonna be interesting
and different than all these other
spider-man's we didn't man a steely went
through an IHOP we've done buffet babe a
superhero stuff before I don't care
about a buffet buddy's still just
another superhero fight give me more
friends give me spider-man chill him
with his friends dubs you want
spider-man homies bring everybody into
the pack can i fact narc yeah I have
snot up a fatty dude why I hop as
burgers now lon they burger pancakes did
you see that they're doing like a burger
with a pancake being delicious over
there and give us your thoughts I just I
feel like we got a little bit more about
what spider-man will be doing in the
Hometown Buffet than just hanging out
with his friend since cuz quite a car
homies so I'm go with Mike Carlson
okay that's one for Mike misread for Oh
God I
nothing makes sense and I love it I
thought the dinner had some good points
about we have seen fights and eateries
before and I also I always something
people always know about me I popped for
friendship I'm huge in the friendship I
like when people are friends and so
seeing a movie that is more about
expanding be cast and seeing how that
friendship works is something that does
appeal to me as much as I do want to see
a food fight I do want to see a
friendship non fight more so I went with
the homies all right it's one one for
many of the points that lon mentioned I
thought just Mike's it got a little bit
more specific as what we were seeing so
there was a
[Music]
and more friends so for that but both
potentially great I love your choices
but yeah I'm going I'm going Mike on
this one Mike takes the lead three to
two right there great here is oh and Dan
I mean chime in Internet if anybody if
anybody's watching this is you you
posited that Golden Corral is a step
above hometown as well right okay here
is question number three as Mike misses
game point for Mike den rare that I have
to say this Dan you need the point
you're gonna be on the ropes in this
fight I'm not sure right on all right
which is better men in black too or just
sitting quietly for 90 minutes and being
alone with your thoughts okay Mike
sitting quietly with one's thoughts Mike
go ahead whenever you feel like it no
movie is too bad to make me prefer
sitting along with my own thoughts my
own negative thoughts we all have a bad
self-image let's be honest we all want
to sit and think about it we want to
just watch a movie it doesn't matter
what's on the screen and then men in
black - one of the better choices
honestly is Lisa some effects some
charismatic actors I don't want to sit
there and go you're worthless I just
re-watched a minute black - it's a
shadow of the first movies depressing
it's more depressing than sitting alone
with childhood thoughts
the effects are terrible there are just
no charisma on the screen and at least
if I'm sitting alone for 90 minutes I
can invent in my head a better sequel to
men in black than sitting and watching
men in black - literally any sequel to
minibike that I can sit quietly and
imagine is better than watching the
actual sequel - men imply if any of us
sit quietly trying to imagine movie all
of a sudden we'll go you shouldn't be in
the entertainment industry Michael this
shouldn't be there'll be a character
that'll be the bad guy that'll say
Michael get out of the business and move
home I don't want that I want to watch
men in black - I'm sorry you're so in
your own head about this Mike but most
of us could sit and imagine something
fun the depths of your imagination it's
limitless a minute black - is there any
limit ed sequel - to the first one in
black movie and that's we're depressing
to me alright time first off Mike I'm
sorry someone hurt you dan you I think
you smoked with the more general
effective for people that like we're not
all going to go down this star system
are you Mike but yeah
you can invent some some kind of
enjoyable journey so for me dan made the
better argument Danielle
max was too real for me personally the
that's one of those ones where I had to
take myself out of it and say not
everyone has the same but everyone has
what I like to call the little hater
yeah everyone has intrusive horrible
thoughts and so because I don't want to
prep I don't want to put my own my own
project my own stuff onto that poor poor
movie I'm gonna go with Dan all right
Dan you just tied up this ballgame
that's good Nick Mundy you voted for
yeah Nick what do you say
what were you do you land on this all
right thank Mike okay yeah I mean never
mind I there's a mistake to ask look
look we all have those thoughts those
thoughts are real oh I've got to think
of a minute black eye would be renderman
black we ready listen we all get sad
sometimes and that's okay everybody I
learned that from inside out let's go
question number one action moving to cry
daring this question um all right which
MCU character would you most want to
take car shopping with you which MCU
characters you want to take car shot
[Music]
five why did you look at me like that
because we're talking about Subaru
earlier all right ray throw in a hat or
Thor okay
- I Tony Stark
Stark okay we have to work obviously we
would be living a living Tony Stark all
right 20 seconds begin for Mike as soon
as he speaks when you're going car
shopping you want your bro with you you
want somebody just to be there and go
yeah that guy's ripping you off this is
cool look at that red that's a cool red
that's what Thor is gonna do he's gonna
hang out the
you gonna go have some beers there's no
pressure on a Tony Stark meanwhile it's
gonna have a bunch of [ __ ] I want to
know the oh the specifications of this
it's gonna be so annoying
the war is just gonna be like yeah it
looks good the seats look great and
you're gonna be like thanks Thor I'm
buying this car Thor has no experience
with the earth economy he's not gonna be
able to know a good deal or bad deal and
that's what you really want when you go
car shopping with somebody not somebody
to hang out with somebody that can be
the good cop bad cop and get a good deal
Tony Stark is a fast talker
he's got the resources plus he'll be
entertaining to sit there for the two
and a half hours where they print out
all that stuff for you to sign Thor's
just gonna be like oh look at that bone
over there no I want a guy this
entertaining yeah you know he's it gonna
be so annoying it's gonna be like your
dad they're like oh this isn't a good
deal I just want to get this done I
don't want to have like all we're gonna
save $200 and Tony Stark is gonna be
like researching stuff we're gonna be
there for 12 hours that one you just
picked the best possible person you are
shopping with I want to save that $200
Tony Stark is gonna be able to know how
to get you the best deal that's what you
want in a car shopping friend I getting
out with my friends and be cool anytime
I want someone's gonna get me a deal all
right and again we are tied up three
three this is game point
long yeah Mike had a great idea for why
Thor would be like a cool friend to hang
out with like he'd be the good MCU tries
to be your bro but Dan did a much better
point of really talking about car
shopping and why you'd want Tony to be
part of that specific activity so I'm
going with that
Danielle Radford yeah unfortunately I do
have to I have to agree with that one
like I love Thor I wanna hang out with
Thor Thor someone you would like to get
a beer with but if I want to go and just
buy a car I'm gonna go by myself if I
want to bring someone to buy a car it's
because I want someone who actually
knows what they're talking about and so
because of that you have to go with the
dude who builds things so you gotta go
Tony dan Morel you just had a comeback
victory you want movies fights parties
[Applause]
that's great what you take with you blow
the trailer from the MCU Thor because
while everyone's given like autographs
out mm-hmm
like you hate my friends Thor you can do
like a quick commercial for you oh you
can't do it cuz he's dead I mean yeah
but Dad it would be a lot but yeah that
is true in the scheme dies dan great
stuff that way I mean Gracie far away
this was like so much dumb and fun to be
a part of and to just be privy to in the
best way Mike in the best way yes Mike's
mad
uh-huh I mean yeah he had Dan on the
ropes and he let him slip out of his
grass Mike how does that feel well
it's unfair I guess oh I'm not good at
this show I think you came in exactly
what you are how I'm sorry I lost my
temper about the specifics thing oh no
trying to get better you say f-word you
told me that I told you to shut up
yeah this was a whole nother Dan Merle
when you want guys I understand now why
nobody roots for me to win no I have no
excuse other than I just what's that I
wouldn't take you to buy a car you
wouldn't take me to my car you shouldn't
because I'm very bad I drink I shrink
from confrontation except for on this
show and I I would I'm not good at beg
like deal-making so that would be the
right choice I would not be the good
person I'd be worried you get all
hot-headed and drop f-bombs in the
office as we're trying to sign a paper
no no no I only am aggressive in
situations where there's no possibility
that anyone is actually gonna physically
this is the truth Dan lots of lots of
funny stuff today well fought any any
shout out to any uh no thank you for
coming in and pre-taping it's it's built
around me being out of the office so I
appreciate you structuring your schedule
I thought it was because of us yeah most
money and I couldn't do the real thing
yeah it's our scheduling lied to me okay
well we lied to everyone
to get you here
none of us had a good schedule huh yeah
Nick Monday it's it's always a friggin
treat when you come by and it goes on
the last movie foots oh yeah that's why
I will be doing this next week Nick and
any other any other news notes oh you
want a shout-out no all right thanks
buddy Mike Carlson yeah super funny
stuff thank you very much for yuge what
do you got just a podcast arrived if you
like theme parks it's a podcast that I'm
doing if this is a little shout out this
is a shirt we're now selling it's a
Botanica sput he's called pot Tana cush
we came up with like a gas station pot
version of a Botanica so hell yeah I
don't know by the way I don't none of us
well maybe one of our coats but not me
so yeah listen to the-- the theme bar
michael eisner just retweeted us which
is very exciting
whoa we want eyes please Michael Eisner
if you're watching movie fights which I
know you are and you're upset that this
is the last one how many times you've
been the galaxy's edge I even three I'll
be going for next week I'm I'm been long
thank you for holding it down in fact so
and what a pleasure to be here on the
very last movie that is incorrect Dennis
let me fat check your ass now not true
please continue though hearing on movie
fights and upcoming future but but it's
not because there will be more also lon
will be appeared Danielle Radford thank
you for chiming in with your awesome
opinions and thoughts and whatnots thank
you how those polls I have to go thanks
Danielle yeah we all got to go thanks JT
okay yeah these guys got to get to a
meeting other people have places to go
please hood hoot owl nation and follow
me at how Rudnick on Twitter and
Instagram thanks for watching bye-bye
we all have meetings
you